In this lecture we are going to talk
about how to improve the instantiation
of the vector space model.
This is the continued discussion of the
vector space model.
We're going to focus on how to improve
the instantiation of this model.
In the previous lecture, you have seen
that with
simple same instantiations of the vector
space model.
We can come up with a simple scoring function
that would give us basically a count of
how many unique query terms of matching
the document.
We also have seen that this function
has a problem.
As shown on this slide,
in particular, if you look at these
three documents, they will all get the
same score because they matched 3
unique query words.
But intuitively we would like D4 to
be ranked above D3 and D2 is
really non relevant.
So the problem here is that
this function could not capture.
At the following heuristics:
First, we would like to
give more credit to D4 because
it matched the presidential more times
than these three;
Second,
Intuitively, matching presidential
should be more important than matching
about because about this very common
word that occurs everywhere. It doesn't
really carry that much content.
So in this natural, let's see how we
can improve the model to solve these
two problems.
It's worth thinking at this point about
the
"why do we have these pro problems?"
If we look back at assumptions we have
made while instantiating the vector
space model, we will realize that
the problem
is really coming from some of the
assumptions.
In particular, it has to do with how we
place the vectors in the vector space.
So then, naturally, in order to fix
these problems, we have to revisit
those assumptions.
Perhaps we will have to use different
ways to instantiate the vector space
model.
In particular, we have to place the
vectors in a different way.
So let's see
how can improve this.
One natural thought is, in order to
consider multiple times of the term in
the document, we should consider the
term frequency instead of just absence
or presence.
In order to consider the difference
between a document
where aquarium occurred multiple times
and one where the query term occurs
just once, we have to consider the term
frequency:
The count of a term in the document.
In the simplest model, we only model
the presence and absence of the time.
We ignore the actual number of times
that term occurs in the document. So
let's add this back so we can do then
represent a document by a vector with
term frequency as elements.
So that is to say,
now the elements of both queries vector and
document vector will not be 0 or 1s,
but instead they will be the counts
of
word in the query or the document.
So this would bring in additional
information about the document. So this
can be seen as a more accurate
representation of our documents.
So now let's see what the formula would
look like if we change this
representation.
So as you see on this slide we still
use DOT product,
and so the formula looks very similar
in the form.
In fact it looks identical, but inside
the sum of course Xi and Yi
are now different,
and all the counts of word I in the query
and in the document.
Now at this point I also suggest you to
pause the lecture for a moment and just
think about how we can interpret the
score of this new function.
It's doing something very similar to
what the simplest VSM is doing.
But because of the change of the
vector,
now the new score has a different
interpretation.
Can you see the difference?
And it has to do with the consideration
of multiple occurrences of the same
term in a document.
More important, they would like to know
whether this would fix the problems of
the simplest of vector space model.
So let's look at this example again.
So suppose we change the vector
representation into term frequency vectors.
Now let's look at these three documents
again.
The query vector is the same because
all these words occur exactly once in
the query, so the vector is 001 vector.
And in fact, D2 is also
essentially representing the same way,
because none of these words has been
repeated many times as a result of the
score is also the same, still 3.
The same goes for D3.
And we still have a 3.
But D4 would be different.
Because now presidential occured twice here.
So the element for presidential in
the document factor would be 2 instead
of 1.
As a result,
now the score for D4 is high.
It's 4 now.
So this means,
by using term frequency we can now rank
D4 above D2 and D3
as we hope to.
So this solved the problem
with D4.
But we can also see that,
D2 and D3 are still treated in the same
way.
They still have identical scores, so it
did not fix the problem here.
So how can we fix this problem?
Intuitively, we would like to give more
credit for matching presidential than
matching about, but how can we solve
the problem in a general way?
Is there any way to determine which
word should be treated more
importantly, and which word can be
basically ignored
about is such a word
at which does not really care that
much content?
We can essentially ignore that we
sometimes call such a word stop word.
Those are generally very frequently
occur everywhere matching it doesn't
really mean anything, but
computationally.
How can we capture that?
So again, I encourage you to think a
little bit about this.
Can you come up with any statistical
approaches to somehow distinguish
presidential from about?
If you think about it for a moment,
you will realize that what differences that
words like about occurs everywhere.
So if you count the occurrence of the
word in the whole collection,
then we would see that about
has much higher frequency than
presidential
which tends to occur only in some
documents.
So this idea
suggest that we could somehow use
global statistics of terms or some
other information to try to down
weight
the
element that for about in the vector
representation of D2.
At the same time, we hope to somehow
increase the weight of presidential in
the vector of these three.
If we can do that,
then we can expect the D2 will get
the overall score to be less than 3.
While D3 will get the score above 3,
then we would be able to rank this lead
on top of D2.
So how can we do this systematically?
Again, we can rely on some statistical
counts, and in this case the particular
idea is called the inverse document
frequency.
We have seen document frequency as one
signal used in the modern retrieval
functions.
We discussed this in previous lecture,
so here's a specific way of using it.
Document frequency is the count of
documents that contain a particular
term.
Here we said inverse document frequency
because we actually want to reward a word
that doesn't occur in many documents.
And so the way to incorporate this into
our vector representation is then to modify
the frequency count.
By multiplying it by the idea of the
corresponding word as shown here.
If we can do that, then we can
penalize
common words
which generally have a low IDF and
reward rare words
which
will have high IDF.
So more specifically, the IDF can be
defined as a logarithm of (M + 1) / K,
where M is the total number of
documents in the collection, K is the
DF or document frequency, the total
number of documents containing the word
W.
Now if we plot this function
by varying k,
then you will see the curve would look
like this.
In general, you can see it would give a
higher value for a low DF word, a rare
word.
You can also see the maximum value of
this function is log of M + 1.
Will be interesting for you to think
about what's minimum value for this
function?
This could be interesting exercise.
Now a specific function
may not be as important as the
heuristic to simply penalize
popular terms.
But it turns out that this particular
function form has also worked very
well.
Now, whether there is a better form of
function here is still open research
question,
but it's also clear that if we use a
linear panelization like what's shown
here with this line,
then it may not be as reasonable as the
standard IDF.
In particular, you can see the
difference.
In the standard IDF,
and we somehow have a turning point
here.
After this point they were gonna say
these terms are essentially not very
useful.
They can be essentially ignored
and this makes sense when the term
occurs so frequently, and let's say a
term occurs in more than 50% of the
documents, then the term is unlikely
very important, and it's basically a
common term.
It's not very important to match this
word, so with the standard idea you
can see it's basically assuming that
they all have lower weights.
There's no difference.
But if you look at the linear
panelization at this point that there
is some difference.
So intuitively we
want to focus more on the
discrimination of Low DF words
rather than these
common words.
Of course, which one works better still
has to be validated by using the
empirical created dataset and we have
to use users to judge which results are
better.
So now let's see how this can solve
problem 2.
Alright, so now let's look at the two
documents again.
Now, without the IDF weighting
before, we just have term frequency
vectors, but with IDF weighting,
we now can adjust the TF weight by
multiplying with the IDF value.
For example, here we can see is
adjustment, and in particular for about
there is adjustment by using the IDF
value of about which is smaller than
the IDF value of presidential.
So if you look at these, the IDF will
distinguishing these two words as a
result of adjustment here would be
larger, would make this weight larger.
So if we score with these new vectors,
then what would happen is that of
course they share the same weights for
news and campaign.
But the matching of about and
presidential with discriminate them.
So now as a result of IDF weighting,
we will have D3 to be ranked
above D2 becauses it matched
rare word
whereas D2 matched common word.
So this shows that the IDF weighting
can solve problem 2.
So how effective is this model in
general?
When we use TF IDF weighting, let's
look at the obvious documents that we
have seen before
nicely. These are the new scores of the
new documents,
but how effective is this new weighting
method
and new scoring function?
So now let's see
overall how effective is this new
ranking function with TF IDF weighting?
Here we show all the five documents
that we have seen before, and these are
their scores.
Now we can see the scores for the first
4 documents here
seem to be quite reasonable.
They are as we expected.
However, we also see a new problem.
Because Now D5
here, which did not have a very high
score with our simplest vector space
model, now actually has a very high
score.
In fact, it has the highest score here.
So this creates a new problem.
This is actually a common phenomenon in
designing retrieval functions.
Basically, when you try to fix one
problem, you tend to introduce other
problems and that's why it's very
tricky how to design effective ranking
function and what's the best ranking
function.
Is there open research questions
researchers are still working on that?
But in the next few lectures, we'll
are also gonna talk about some additional
ideas to further improve this model and
try to fix this problem.
So to summarize this lecture we've
talked about how to improve the vector
space model, and we've got to improve
the instantiation of the vector space
model based on TF IDF weighting.
So the improvement mostly is on the
placement of the vector
where we give higher weight to a term
that occured many times in the document
but infrequently in the whole
collection.
And we have seen that this improvement
model indeed works better than the
simplest vector space model.
But it also still has some problems.
In the next lecture, we're going to
look at the how to
address these additional problems.